اذا لضربه مكيفك تبيعات تثقل كاهل القياده
العسكريه الروسيه وتزيد من حرجها الداخليه
اخطاء متكرره وفشل تلو الاخر جعلها في
مرمى الغاضبين من المواليين لحربها على
جارتها الغربيه اوكرانيا لم تجد وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه نفسها قادره على انتظار
نتائج التحقيق في الضربه القاسيه
فحملت باللوم او حملت اللوم بالحادثه
لجنوددها الضحايا لكن كيف ذلك
السبب في هواتفهم المحموله التي استخدمها
بشكل مكثف ما سهل من استهدافهم ارتفعت
حصيله قتل الجيش الروسي الى 89 جنديا وفقا
متحدث باسم الوزاره
الذي قال ان عدد رفاقنا القتل ارتفع الى
89 بعد العثور على مزيد من الجثث تحت
الانقاض واضاف ان هناك حاليا لجنه تحقق
لجرائم ملابسات ما حدث لكن من الواضح منذ
الان ان السبب الرئيسي هو ان العسكريين
شغله واستخدموا على نطاق واسع هواتفهم
المحموله في منطقه تطالها اسلحه العدو بما
يتعارض مع حضر استعمالها
لكن من الواضح بالفعل ان السبب الرئيسي
لما حدثته والاستخدام المكثف من قبل افراد
الفوج للهواتف المحموله ما جعلهم في
متناول اسلحه العدو وسامح هذا للعدو
بتحديد احداثيات مواقع
الصاروخيه يتم حاليا
ممثله في المستقبل نتيجه
العداله
لم يقنع الغاضبين الذين صبوا جاما غضبهم
القاده العسكريين وليس الرئيس بلادي مير
بوتان الذي لم يعلق حتى الان على الهجوم
احد الغاضبين المراسل الحربي الروسي
البارز والحاصل على وسام الشجاعه من بوت
عام 20 22 ونتحدث هنا عن سيميوم بيجوف
الذي شك في الاسباب التي سردتها الوزاره
قائلا ان اوكرانيا حددت القاعده الروسيه
بالطائرات المسيره او المخابرات وليس عن
طريق الهواتف وكتب على تلغرام قائلا ان
قصه الهواتف المحموله ليست مقنعه للغايه
نادرا ما اقول هذا ولكن هذا هو الحال
عندما يكون من الافضل التزام الصمت على
الاقل حتى نهايه التحقيق واشعار الى ان
عدد القتلى سيرتفع بدورهم ارجع مسؤولون
بالاستخبارات البريطانيه الضربه الى
الممارسات العسكريه الروسيه غير المهنيه
وكتبت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه عبر تويتر
انه بالنظر الى حجم الضرر هناك احتمال
واقعي ان تكون ذخيره تم تخزينها بالقرب من
اماكن اقامه قوه الروسيه والتي انفجرت
اثناء الضربه ما تسبب في حدوث انفجارات
ثانويه ايضا واضافت الوزاره ان الجيش
الروسي لديه سجل في تخزين الذخيره بشكل
غير امن منذ فتره طويله قبل الحرب الحاليه
لكن هذا الحادث يصلي الضوء على مدى مساهمه
الممارسه غير المهنيه في ارتفاع معدل
الخسائر في روسيا
[موسيقى]